so hi there guys hello Conan Christopher
O'Brien wow that's that's impressive
that's actually my middle name
how did you know that we have our ways
yes and hello to you mr. Andy Lester
Richter how'd you find that up I
introduced your uncle to a mr. Jack
Daniels that's great very nice very nice
now just relax calm down everything's
fine I understand that you two guys were
in New York when our people called you
up what are you doing here in New York
what's going on yes we came in two
nights ago for cone con 94 cone con 94
I'm sorry I don't know what that is
first annual Late Night with Conan
O'Brien fan convention wow this is uh
this is actually the first I've heard of
it well it went kind of unannounced
thanks to our PR department seventeen
hey calm down calm down all right now I
understand that the two of you brought a
videotape of that event is that true
yeah can we show it sure we can that'll
be great
let's show the videotape of home camera
yeah video
Dana Rawley please it was held in a
Holiday Inn and rancic a movie you guys
wrote rented a hotel meeting room is
that it well it was a hotel room that's
it welcome karna files see there's me
alright and that's me we were selling
memorabilia so
seventy-three that's got Eartha Kitt
Coenen buttons Mac's buttons X's head
next to the max buttons
I hardly any buttons I love Andy Conan
space happy but over here we have the
Andy buttons and bumper stickers if you
have a car we don't own cars we also
have at it shows us the tape audio Joe
yes
also necks out at a Weinberg family
songbook that's max and turn me a guide
and Conan's tax return for the last
three years if your income that's very
nice this is us waiting for people to
show up all right I see haha
we sat around and talked about the show
and stuff but pretty some people came oh
no they are there they were each fan
received a complimentary Conan paper
hair very nice it got quite crowded I
think there were must have been seven
people there I think it was six
really yeah well I didn't count this guy
from me oh no way what's what's the deal
with him well that's what you call a
mix-up
well time for activities annexed
Weinberg look-alike contest
and we have some nice entrance and
interestingly the winner has never seen
the show okay and then the big moment
our guest speaker arrived yes very
exciting this is what you you guys got a
guest speaker that's terrific
you did this actually you went it's for
the fans Conan alright alright well
let's let's keep rolling we'll iron that
out later show it Dana Joe is a ship on
the ocean and therefore I am the rudder
I utilize my comments and remarks to
constantly redirect things unseen its
destination an island of perfect
entertainment
[Applause]
Andy sign is your book any book the
couch there's a lot of things you don't
know about Andy that I do Emily and we
finished the game with a simple ceremony
[Applause]
there was Danny's idea yeah I kind of
figured yeah corn this is taken out of
context that's the end of cone
[Applause]
you're not supposed to see that but I
waited takes over that we thought we'd
take them
[Applause]
thanks for
thanks for showing us the tape and I
guess I'll see you guys later on thanks
Corning and we'll see you in Cleveland
the next weekend not now all right
William and Robert greevil